recently Jen and I were teammates on
Hollywood game night we had such a great
time you know we won it all
but we wanted to play again but this
time against each other all right well
you man do the hosting honors I would be
honored okay take it over welcome you
guys played this game on the show and
even though you won overall you lost
this game but let's take a look at how
you guys
[Applause]
that was intense and I became a New York
cab driver in that game but today
Jennifer hey yes one of you two will be
a winner now here are the rules we play
one team at a time Kelly and Jen you'll
be the designated drivers for your teams
the rest of you will take turns being
the passengers passengers you need to
get your driver to recognize where you
want to go without saying the name of
the locations you failed your team gets
one point for every correct answer you
guys got it your team's going first cuz
you guys we got your team here we go
American Ninja Warrior
we got sandy up here Gardner read in
Lady Gaga fan will she's getting into
character Jennifer yes this is for
bragging rights are you ready on the
clock before you go on I will show you
the name of where you trying to go you
get them to guys are you guys ready yeah
Kelly keep it civil this is for fun can
be cool ready yeah okay here we go ready
set go oh all right kids love to go
there
it's my oh there for um for Christmas
ideas for Christmas ideas toys
this is a place revered this is a place
where you go and get your license like
the fashion district
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
Jennifer
[Applause]
the super-sweet Jennifer Gaga with
screaming answers like her like the
Pangolin you got nine points team Kelly
has to get ten correct to win it you
guys ready Kelly can you introduce us to
your team oh my god I'm so excited can
we just play yes okay no ten answers and
they will have Kelly Clarkson defeating
the legendary Jennifer Garner it's gonna
happen okay are you ready go grab him
she's driving you got 60 seconds on the
clock nine answers is the score to beat
we begin now going to pump iron this
song that everybody sings at the
weddings place on the East Coast
royal people live there everybody goes
there and Italy to take their picture
next to it sideways I'm going to hitting
on yards I'm going to place the smallest
country in the world everybody goes
there to pray the Vatican this
we're getting the parts right now the
judges are looking at the tape Jennifer
and Kelly come on up here we need to
look at the tape here now there was some
skullduggery that was going we like to
keep it above board here Kelly the last
to the show what does it mean now
establish yourself as one of the great
game players on the planet I'm just a
proud so proud to be with this amazing
team and I look forward to being on
Kelly's team again instead of against
her Hollywood game after them
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this